gilbert casasus professeur en études
européennes bonjour j'ai eu peur qu'elle
s'ajuste merci d'être avec mondial sur
arte france vous est confiné à fribourg
en suisse comment se passe votre
confinement comment les suisses vivent
le confinement et quelle est la
situation à north bay qui est
intéressant la suisse est un état
fédéral et je dois vous avouer que je
vis ce confinement de deux façons c'est
à dire que d'une pas en voit une
certaine discipline on voit une certaine
de esprit suisse de bien être attentif à
certaines règles
mais surtout et je crois que ça s'est
extrêmement intéressante loi une grande
différence entre la suisse romande où la
suisse latine un coup donc le tessin il
appuie sa demande à savoir que d'après
des chiffres il y aurait quatre fois
plus de morts en suisse latine qu'en
suisse allemande sur les biens du fait
que notamment le tessin et dans le
canton italien alors de langue italienne
de la suisse a été très touchée étant
donné qu stains comptant qui est
limitrophe de la lombardie mais aussi la
région de genève a été touchée l'arc
lémanique et la suisse allemande a eu
moins de coster et ceci explique cela
néanmoins on s'est entre temps que les
façon de compter le nombre de décès est
différent parce que dans certains
cantons sur l'acte de décès des marques
est mort suite ou que 8,19 et dans
d'autres cantons ce n'est pas le cas et
c'est notamment pas le cas
officiellement de temps quand on voit
des différences important il ne suffit
d'ailleurs que deux choix lire la page
des chronos fiq d'un journal russe
allemand ou un journal suisse
comment ce que je fais quasiment tous
les jours il a vouvoyé véritablement des
différences alors que le mieux et qui
évidemment ne comptons pas ne connaît
pas les frontières cantonales de
frontières deux pays la suisse mais
aussi le luxembourg ou encore
l'allemagne auprès des patients français
est-ce que c'est révélateur d'une
solidarité européenne même si la suisse
ne fait pas partie de l'ue eux
ou d'une france incapable de soigner ses
malades alors il faut pas dire la france
incapable de soigner ses malades
il s'est avéré que il ya eu ce grand col
koster on est dans la région de mulhouse
une louche et à 15 minutes ou 20 minutes
en voiture de balle donc ça a beaucoup
joué mais il faut et je trouve que la
france aurait pu le faire de façon un
peu plus insistantes
et puis surtout plus rapidement remercié
les autorités luxembourgeoises les
autorités allemandes notamment du
bade-würtemberg et les autorités suisses
notamment deux balles d'avoir fait cet
effort
c'est un geste de solidarité et je pense
que nous devrions en à venir réfléchir
justement sur l'importance du geste de
solidarité dans les régions
transfrontalières de solidarité pourtant
on voit qu'il ya une opposition entre
pays du nord et pays du sud certains
pays européens en l'avions déjà
également entamé leur première phase de
déconfinement comme le luxembourg comme
l'allemagne comme la norvège également
d'autres comme la france non est-ce
qu'il faut y voir des stratégies
différentes
tous les pays ne sont pas logés à la
même enseigne dans cette europe
je ne vous cacherai pas mon inquiétude
vis-à-vis de cette séparation entre
l'europe du nord et l'europe du sud l'a
pas seulement pour des raisons
économiques aussi par des hasards je dis
toujours que si bayern de munich avec du
jour but jouer contre le bergamo
d'attentats de bergamo mais y aurait eu
aussi beaucoup plus infectés à munich et
en valière donc c'était des questions en
eau dans le chantier de silic je parle
donc il y à des questions de hasard il
ya aussi des questions liées justement
où dépenses publiques
la france qui a une excellente médecine
quand même eu on le sait par exemple
beaucoup de problèmes financiers dans
les hôpitaux on se rend compte encore
aujourd'hui et il est vrai que il y a là
des différences et qu'il y à des
perceptions également très différentes
je vois au delà de la question nord-sud
envoie une également dont on ne parle
jamais peut-être je suis là des
premières en parler c'est la différence
de perception entre les
pelli où les régions catholiques les
piles et région protestante
hélas la suite c'est un excellent
laboratoire politique pour remarquer que
dans les régions plutôt catholique c'est
la médecine c'est l'humain c'est le bien
commun qui est en tête tandis que dans
les riches dans protestante évangélique
ça dépend comment le lob était comme
emploi c'est plutôt les questions
économiques qui joue un rôle
et d'ailleurs si on prend le débat
suisse on voit de très très grande
différence entre les comptes en
catholiques romands je pense notamment à
fribourg et des comptes en protestant
notamment du riq berd ou les questions
les questions économiques les questions
de commerce joue un très grand rôle un
pays catholique cesse et l'italie selon
divers sondages récents publiés sur le
site du gouvernement italien après 70 %
un peu plus de 70% des personnes
interrogées pensent que la pandémie
détruire l'union européenne environ 55 %
seraient d'accord pour sortir de nos
yeux et ou de l'euro
quel avenir pour bruxelles après cette
très souvent vous chez moi même écrit un
article qui s'appelle l'union européenne
attention danger
je rejoins totalement l'analyse de
jacques delors il y à un véritable
danger mais c'est peut-être justement
parce qu'il ya danger plutôt s'il ya
prise en compte de ce danger l'union
européenne peut s'en sortir à condition
mais je le dis clairement et je
m'adresse notamment aux dirigeants
européens de ne pas avoir peur de
prendre des mesures très dures des
mesures très claires des mesures aussi à
l'encontre de certains pays européens
comme la hongrie qui se comporte de
façon absolument minable ce pourrait
également citer la pologne la république
tchèque et aussi de réfléchir
véritablement ce qui signifie le mot
solidarité européenne d'en revenir
peut-être une idée des perforateurs de
l'europe où on a aidé les uns par
rapport aux autres
on a beaucoup vanté avec raison en
partie madame merkel mais lorsque mme
merkel a dit nous sommes en 1945 il faut
pas oublier si on est allemand que dire
quand il en 1945 c'est se souvenir aussi
que beaucoup de pays
certes les états unis à l'époque mais
pas seulement
ont aidé l'allemagne donc hélas on n'a
pas demandé de rembourser
on n'a pas de demander de prendre des
mesures de prêts ou à long terme et
c'est donc si l'on fait des comparaisons
historiques ayant le courage à la fois
de balayer devant sa porte et
deuxièmement aussi de se dire bah oui il
faut y aller il faut aider les nourrir
je pense que c'est un poids excellence
yen à l'avenir merci c'est le mot de la
fin a remercié l'ingénieur cassation
d'avoir répondu à nos questions je
rappelle que vous êtes professeur en
études européennes